CLIFF LUNGARETTI: Ladies and
gentlemen, Garfunkel herself,
Riki Lindhome.
RIKI LINDHOME: Hello!
Am I sitting here?
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: [INAUDIBLE]
RIKI LINDHOME: That was
clearly not from the special.
That was from last season
of "Another Period."
If you haven't seen it,
it takes place in 1902.
It's like a reality
show set in 1902.
And that's all real stuff
it's based on all real stuff.
That finger contraption is real,
from the turn of the century.
Yeah, those are all
Freud techniques
except for the bicycle.
We're like, we have to
add something to it.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI:
"Yes, and," of course.
RIKI LINDHOME: Yes.
So we had "yes, and"
it so we had the bike.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: Riki, you
are really a renaissance woman.
You are an actress, a
comedian, a musician.
You created "Another Period."
You're a writer on "Another
Period," the showrunner.
Now we have a new special
coming this week with--
RIKI LINDHOME: I've been busy.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: Yeah.
Well, thank you for making
time and coming here to Google.
RIKI LINDHOME: I try to tell
my parents what I do all day.
I'm just like, I don't know.
Everything.
I don't know, just everything.
And they're like, what do you?
It's always different.
It's always, no,
no, no, I gotta go.
And yeah, that's basically
their understanding of my job.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: And you were
here today without your cohort.
You are here without Oates.
RIKI LINDHOME: I
know, I'm so sad.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: No Kate today.
RIKI LINDHOME: She's in
LA doing "Conan" today.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: Oh, I know.
Here we are with Cliff.
So you drew the short
straw, I'm sure.
So Garfunkel and Oates.
Let's just start with
what people need to know.
Why Garfunkel?
RIKI LINDHOME: Well, I
was at a Hall and Oates
concert at the Hollywood Bowl.
And I had really bad seats.
I was waitressing.
I was in the back.
And so basically, you could
only watch it on the monitors.
And the camera had
a closeup of Darryl,
that he had a wind
machine kind of situation.
It was a closeup of Darryl.
And then it was like
Oates and the band.
So Oates was only
in the wide shot
or like the moving
right past him.
And there was no two shot.
It was just Darryl,
and then everyone else.
And for some reason,
that just made me laugh.
And I was like, who set that up?
Like how does it
feel to be Oates?
And then we went from there.
But we didn't realize--
about two years ago,
someone sent us this
"Simpsons" thing where
they had almost the same joke.
We were like [GROANS].
They had something called--
it was like Nash, Oates
and Garfunkel, or something.
But it was close enough.
We were like, well, OK.
Oh well, too late now.
That's our name.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: So, of
course, Kate is Oates.
You are Garfunkel.
How did you guys get together?
RIKI LINDHOME: We were both
auditioning for commercials.
And neither of us were working
because it was all like Maxim
girls, like that Doritos girl.
If you guys remember, it
was all that kind of look.
And then all of a sudden, they
just started casting girls
with big eyes.
And so she and I
just got called back
for everything out of nowhere.
I auditioned for a
couple years, got
dropped by my commercial
agent, never booked anything.
And then out of nowhere,
like Kate and I were just
in all the commercials.
We were like, what is happening?
It didn't last that
long, but we just
kept seeing each
other at callbacks.
And then she came up and
introduced herself to me
at UCB, and then
it went from there.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: And how did
the musician line get into it?
How do you pick up--
RIKI LINDHOME: We just became
like these weird soul mate
friends.
I don't even know
how to explain it.
Like Kate's boyfriend, who
was with her when we met,
on the way home, he's like you
like her more than you like me.
And Kate says she
remembers going like, yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
So yeah.
And then we found out that
we both wrote comedy songs
on our own.
I used to play them in
college, and Kate was playing
these comedy songs around town.
And I would play at parties.
Like we'd been doing it on our
own in an unofficial capacity
for like 10 years.
And so then we're just like,
oh, let's just do this together.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: When was
your first gig together?
RIKI LINDHOME: Gosh.
I think it's been
eight years, maybe.
It's been a long time, yeah.
Yeah, I think it was 2008.
We made this short that Kate
was my imaginary friend,
and it was a musical, and
we wrote the songs for it,
and just made it.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: Very cool.
RIKI LINDHOME: And
some sun, yeah.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: Great.
What is your song process like?
I know, the old creative
process question.
RIKI LINDHOME:
Well, basically it's
evolved because we've found
out what we're good at
and how to do it.
So basically,
we'll have a topic,
and then we just
brainstorm on it forever.
And this is only the
songs that make it.
The songs that don't,
I don't even know.
We just throw them
in the garbage.
But basically, we
brainstorm forever.
We'll have like a 20
page document of anything
we've ever thought
about this topic.
And then she gives it to me,
and I narrow it down and come up
with a title.
And then after I have
the title, I go and do
a first pass of the
lyrics give it to Kate,
she does the first
pass of the melody.
And then we get together
and make it together.
But she just has
these catchy melodies
that are always in her head.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: So
do you guys have ever
go on like a specific bit of
like you want to hit a joke,
and then a song
comes around that?
Or is it--
RIKI LINDHOME: Sometimes,
we'll get a title.
If there's not enough to sustain
a joke for like three minutes,
then we don't do it.
Because some things are
good as one line, but then
what do you say after that?
Its just like I've
got nothing left.
So most things end
up in the garbage
because we can't blow
them out to a whole song.
RIKI LINDHOME: Now this leads
to the very first special,
"Trying To Be Special."
And of course, spoiler
alert, I have seen it
so I'll try and keep it close.
But the special is about
trying to make a special.
RIKI LINDHOME: Yes it is.
It's very meta.
It's basically Kate and
I are in a hotel room
and we had this gig that
you think went really badly.
And we're just like this
sucks We're so tired.
And I'm like, do you think we
should do something different?
She's like I don't know.
And I'm like, well,
we're 36 years old.
We have no husbands,
no real jobs, no kids.
Our lives are amusing.
And she's like, yeah, totally.
Like the only
thing that can make
it better is a comedy special.
And so we're like, oh,
we don't have the money
to make a comedy special.
So we do a fundraiser
concert in order
to make money to be able
to put on the special.
And then you see the
fundraiser concert.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: And this
comes out this coming week,
on Cinco de Mayo--
RIKI LINDHOME:
Cinco de Mayo, yes.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: --May 5th.
It's available on Vimeo.
RIKI LINDHOME: Vimeo, Yeah.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: So
going the digital route?
RIKI LINDHOME: Yeah, we decided
to do something different.
Because Vimeo, they
have the best player.
They just do.
Like businesses use it,
they're the best player.
And you can just download it
and have it on your computer
forever.
And they don't give notes.
You have full, 100%
creative control.
So we were like that feels-- and
the same budget as everywhere
else.
So we're like oh, no notes
and yeah, let's do that.
So that's what we
decided to go with.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: One
thing in the special
that we were talking
about prior is just
the quirkiness of
your guys' characters.
And it makes everything seem
so just spur of the moment.
RIKI LINDHOME: Right.
Some of it is, some of it is.
When we go on
tour, we don't know
what we're going to talk
about when we walk out.
Unless something really
weird happened right before.
Then we're like, OK, we're
going to talk about that.
But usually, we just
walk out and like begin,
and sometimes it goes
better than other times.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI:
You actually said
that you and Kate had--
she introduced herself
at UCB, so improv background?
RIKI LINDHOME: No.
No, we were there
seeing a friend's show.
We were seeing a
Doug Benson show.
And we were both
friends with him.
I made friends with
them on Friendster.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: Oh wow.
RIKI LINDHOME: That's real.
That is real.
He saw some play that
I was in it, and was
like your play is funny.
And I was like, I just
saw you do comedy,
and we were loose acquaintances.
And he like was like
come to my next show,
and that's where I met Kate.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI:
That's actually funny.
I was first exposed to you guys
from Doug Benson's podcast.
RIKI LINDHOME: Really?
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: Yeah.
RIKI LINDHOME: Yeah.
He's been so nice
to us since day one.
He always has us on there.
He's just like been
a good friend to us.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: Very nice.
RIKI LINDHOME: He opened
for us last time we
were in LA just to be nice.
Didn't want any money,
just opened for us.
Yeah, it was cool.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: So
just shifting over
since we saw the "Another
Period" clip to start.
So "Another Period"
is created and written
by you and Natasha Leggero.
And you did say it's like a
reality show based in 1902.
RIKI LINDHOME: Yeah.
We say it's like a family
like the Kardashians moved
into Downton Abbey.
So this is set in America.
It's in Newport, Rhode Island.
These people are not
classy, they're new money.
And they have unlimited
money but it's brand new.
And our dad is a magnet magnate.
He owns all the magnets
in the world, I guess.
And then we just are
like pieces of garbage
that have no problems but
complain all day long.
And "Another Period's", of
course, on Comedy Central.
Season two comes out in June?
RIKI LINDHOME: June 15th.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: Great.
June 15th, Comedy Central.
How did that come about
with you and Natasha?
Was that just a
conversation of imagine--
RIKI LINDHOME: So Natasha and
I, we went on a charity trip
to Senegal for Malaria No More.
Which is actually an
incredible organization.
They're actually curing malaria.
Like they're actually
doing stuff, it's so crazy.
But I love that company.
And we went to Senegal,
and we just bonded.
It's so hot.
And we didn't know what we
were doing, and it was intense.
And so we just became friends.
And then, when we
were flying back,
Natasha was like I
looked at your IMDB.
And I'm like yeah, OK.
She's like you have like
80 credits on there,
and how many of
those things have you
been in that are actually funny?
I was like that a good question.
I was like, I don't know, two?
And she's like I have zero.
I have like 50 things,
and zero things are funny.
And she's like, I feel
like that's weird.
She's like, I think we need
to write stuff and make
funny stuff because why
is everything not funny?
And I'm like, all
right, good point.
And so we started trying
to come up with an idea,
and then we were really stuck.
And so we went out and
drank a bunch of wine,
and then came up with the idea.
As you do.
When you're like fuck
it, let's get wasted.
And you're like,
I know the idea!
Like it's a terrible creative
process but it totally works.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI:
Speaking of your IMDB,
I found myself watching
"Million Dollar Baby" recently
and I was totally blindsided.
And I was like, oh my god.
That's an intense film.
RIKI LINDHOME: I'm a
renaissance woman, as you say.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: There you go.
That's right.
RIKI LINDHOME: That's
my first movie.
It was so crazy.
I just thought it was
going up from there.
I was like my first movie I
was ever in won the Oscar?
Like sky's the limit.
And then I still didn't get an
agent for another two or three
years.
I was like, OK, so it's
going to be slower.
But it was really awesome.
It was crazy.
My first scene was with Clint
Eastwood, and Hilary Swank
and Margo Martindale
that I ever did.
I'm like, OK, it's fine.
I'm fine.
I totally deserve to be here.
I just-- you know.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI:
Well, congratulations
on the Best Picture.
RIKI LINDHOME: Yeah.
Thank you, thank you.
It really changed my life.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI:
Just so you guys know,
we will be taking questions
from the audience.
There are microphones
in both the aisles
if you want to just go up there.
I'll call on you, and
do it like school.
RIKI LINDHOME: I feel
like you have my back
and you clapped the hardest, so
you have to ask me a question
and get the ball rolling.
I just like your
whole energy, and it
made me feel good as I
was walking out here.
AUDIENCE: I'm sold.
RIKI LINDHOME: So not
to put you on the spot,
but you have to think
of something to ask me.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: You can wait.
Why don't you guys
take a few minutes--
RIKI LINDHOME: OK.
Think about it and we'll
get back to you, OK?
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: If
I was in the audience
and I wasn't lucky enough
to be moderating this,
I would ask you a very
important question.
What is it like
dating Fozzie Bear?
RIKI LINDHOME: It's pretty sexy.
He's pretty smooth.
I actually loved being
on "The Muppets."
I was a big Muppets fan.
I know people always say it.
They're like I always
loved "The Flash."
And it's like no, you didn't.
No, you didn't.
You didn't love that growing up.
But I actually did
love the Muppets.
I would have Miss Piggy birthday
cakes and I just loved it.
So it was pretty cool.
I don't know how it worked.
I didn't know there was so many
people controlling a Muppet.
There's like
monitors everywhere,
and you're on this
raised platform.
And it's pretty--
CLIFF LUNGARETTI:
What is the process
of doing a scene with Fozzie?
RIKI LINDHOME: There's just
so many people involved.
There's so many actors making
this thing come to life.
There's like one guy
that does the left arm,
and they're all working
in this-- they just
know each other so well.
And they have like these
things on their heads
where they can see through
the Mup-- it's just
a whole technical process
that they find very easy.
And the guy who
played Fozzie also
does the voice of
Piggy and Animal.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: Oh wow.
RIKI LINDHOME: So his talent
is basically unlimited.
He does all three
of those himself.
What do you got?
AUDIENCE: Sure, yeah.
I'm ready.
So I guess, first of all,
on behalf of all of us,
thank you so much for coming.
RIKI LINDHOME: Thank
you for having me.
AUDIENCE: I'm a huge fan,
and have been for years.
I like to feel that your song
"I Don't Know Who You Are"
is my own personal anthem.
RIKI LINDHOME: I know, right?
AUDIENCE: I'm terrible
with names and faces,
and it's really your fault.
RIKI LINDHOME: Yeah.
Don't you think?
For people who don't know
what this is, we have a song,
it's called "I Don't
Know Who You Are,"
which you can figure
out what that is.
But it's people
who come up to you,
and they know who you are but
you don't know who they are,
and they get mad.
And we have this like
hypothesis that it's
their fault because they're
not interesting enough.
They don't have a thing.
And so they blend, and
then it's not our fault.
AUDIENCE: So that's amazing.
So thank you so much
for opening up my life
like that and [INAUDIBLE].
So I discovered-- you guys are
amazing, Garfunkel and Oates.
There's another
comedy folk duo I'm
sure you've heard of called
Flight of the Conchords.
RIKI LINDHOME: Yes.
AUDIENCE: And it seems
such an odd thing to me
that there were two comedy folk
duos that were so hysterically
funny, had really successful
songwriting careers,
and then made specials where
they incorporated those songs.
Were you guys inspired
by each other?
Do you collaborate?
RIKI LINDHOME: Totally.
AUDIENCE: Do you guys all hang
out in some really cool bar
somewhere?
Where is this bar?
RIKI LINDHOME: I've never met
Bret, but I know Jermaine.
And Jermaine is actually
on the upcoming season
of "Another Period."
He's doing two episodes this
season, which is so cool.
He flew in from New Zealand
just to do the show,
and he plays a priest.
Like every single
thing he says is funny,
so we were very, very excited.
But Jermaine and I actually
became friends on Twitter.
He just sent me a DM
one day being like, hey,
there's like eight people in
the world who do what we do.
What's up?
And I was like, I know,
it's so crazy, right?
And he was like how
weird is it we're
in comedy folk--
like who does this?
I'm like I don't know.
And then we've just been Twitter
acquaintances since then.
And then, he agreed to do
the show, which was so cool.
AUDIENCE: So no plans for some
grand mega band or something?
RIKI LINDHOME: I
would be so down.
AUDIENCE: Comedy
folk court quartet?
RIKI LINDHOME: I wish.
I hope.
I'm going to put-- I don't
know Bret, but I would love to.
Just putting it out.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: Now
it's out in the world.
RIKI LINDHOME: Yeah.
It's in the universe now.
It's going to happen.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: Thank you.
RIKI LINDHOME: Thanks.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI:
Thank you, buddy.
RIKI LINDHOME: That "I
Don't Know Who You Are"
song was really weird
because everyone liked takes
your point of view, which is
like I don't remember people
either.
You put yourself in
the hero position.
But then one person came
up to us after a show
and they're like
that song is so mean.
And I was like, wait, why?
What?
He goes people always forget me.
And I was like, oh god.
And he put himself in the--
don't you guys put yourself
in the hero shoes?
Like you hear a bit about
other people being annoying,
they're like I am annoying.
Like you don't put
yourself-- I don't know,
I thought that was so strange
and I didn't want to say.
I was like, I think you
should change your perspective
on this.
Do you forget people?
And he's like not really.
Sorry man, I don't know.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI:
Well, speaking of that,
another one of your songs
seems like it may come across
as aggressive to people,
"Pregnant Women Are Smug."
Have you ever had any
backlash from that?
RIKI LINDHOME: Yeah, but not
any that you care about it.
[LAUGHTER]
I don't know.
Like what's the-- I
don't like that like.
I'm like OK.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI:
Because they're smug.
RIKI LINDHOME: Right.
Like it doesn't ever
hurt my feelings ever.
But so many more
people have been like--
like Amanda Palmer is pregnant,
and she sang "Pregnant Women
Are Smug" on her whole tour.
She like took it on.
Like we got these onesies made
that say "My mommy is smug,"
and they just like sold out.
People just buy them.
So I think probably for
gag gifts for baby showers.
But I think most people own it.
I feel like if you're
pregnant and acting like that,
you know it.
And like you can like,
you're allowed to.
You're just allowed to do
that, but I think you know it.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI:
The woman card.
RIKI LINDHOME: The
woman card, I know.
The pregnant woman card.
That's more powerful than
the woman card, I think.
Because no one can
say that you're not
going through whatever you
say you're going through.
Like no, my ankles hurt.
And you're like OK.
Like you can't be like no, they
don't because you have no idea.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI:
Speaking of your songs,
I'm dating a 31-year-old
woman who loves "29/31".
RIKI LINDHOME: Oh, cool.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: So thank
you for that from her.
RIKI LINDHOME: Does she feel
like there's no one left,
and that's why she's dating you?
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: Maybe.
RIKI LINDHOME: No,
I'm totally joking.
[LAUGHTER]
CLIFF LUNGARETTI:
That's exactly what
I said when she was like,
oh man, that's so cool.
And I was just
like, wait a second.
This got really real.
RIKI LINDHOME:
It's so funny when
people take that-- some people
have taken it seriously.
Like I was at a baseball
game the other day,
and this girl turns around.
She's like are you the girl
from the "29/31" video?
And I was like, yeah, yeah.
And she didn't
think we wrote it.
She thought we were like
acting in this video.
And she's like I relate
to that song so much.
I'm 30, and I know my life
is about to get really bad.
And I was like no,
it's just a joke.
It's not real.
It's not necessarily that,
it's just like a joke.
It was about basically me and
Kate's perspectives on love,
and we weren't even
29, 31 at the time.
We just thought those
were funny numbers.
We were like 31
and 33, but we're
like nah, that's not as funny.
Yeah.
But she's like I just know
everything's going to get bad,
and I got to meet someone soon.
And she was so
pretty, and I was OK.
Sorry, maybe you shouldn't
watch that video.
It's just a joke.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI:
That's said, out of all
of the songs you and
Kate have put together,
what is like your go-to?
Like which is your
favorite baby, basically?
What's your favorite?
RIKI LINDHOME: My
favorite song is one
that we've actually
never played.
It's just on an album,
but it was on our TV show.
It's called "Such a
Loser," and it's an anthem
for people who are trying.
Because just like you
guys are on the internet.
You understand when you
put something out there,
you just get all this criticism.
And it feels like there's
like this hierarchy where
it's winners, people who
just don't do anything
but comment on it,
and then losers.
But we just feel like
those should be switched.
Like winners are just like they
won, you got it like they did.
But the people who try and
the people who comment on it,
should be like a
different hierarchy.
So that the commenters
should just be like whatever.
And so we wrote a song
in praise of people
who are trying and failing
because if you're failing that
much, you're trying that much.
So it's not a funny song.
It's totally
sentimental, but I think
it's the best thing
we've ever written.
Yeah, look it up.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: Great.
RIKI LINDHOME: We have
a cartoon made of it,
and people play
it for their kids.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: With
your songwriting process,
you seem to then
also go into video.
So what is that like?
Do you ever get bogged
down in like, oh, this
would look great visually, so
we should add it to the song?
Or is that well after the fact?
RIKI LINDHOME: Nope.
We don't have that
kind of forethought.
We're just like,
oh, I don't know.
I guess we'll just
film some stuff.
Yeah, we don't really ever think
about that part of the song.
And like for "Such
a Loser," we had
it animated by these people in
Boston, who are so incredible.
And they just sent us this
thing, and Kate and I,
we always have a million notes.
We're so nit-picky, it takes us
forever for us to do anything.
And they sent it, and we just
started crying, both of us.
And we're like this is perfect.
And they were,
well, we have like
four rounds of notes built-in.
And we're like no, love it.
So sometimes it's
like that easy.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI:
I was going to say,
so for you, notes are really
a bad thing in general.
RIKI LINDHOME: No, no.
I always have so many notes.
But this one, it was perfect.
And so you don't want to-- if
it's perfect, it's perfect.
But yeah, I'm like pretty
hands-on with everything.
I like to be in every
moment of everything.
Like Natasha and I are editing
"Another Period" right now,
and we're in the editing
room from like 10:00 to 8:00,
every single day.
We just get our
nails done in there.
Yeah, we're hands-on.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: Great.
Sorry, I thought I
was getting signaled.
In "Another Period" coming up,
what can we look forward to?
You mentioned that
Jermaine's going to be on.
RIKI LINDHOME: Jermaine,
and Andrew Reynolds
is on this new season, playing
like a dashing prince-type
person.
Harriet Tubman is
in our premiere,
which is so crazy that
now she's on money-- well,
about to be on money--
because we have her
as a-- she's a branding expert.
We have her as like
this Oprah-type person,
and she's basically
like how do you
think I'm the only
name associated
with this entire movement?
She's like, I did that
shit, like on our show.
People are going to have
mixed reactions to it,
they really are, and
we're prepared for that.
But it is funny if you watch.
Because you think about
it how did one person--
how did that happen?
Like there was so many people.
But yeah, so you just
think through history.
And now, she's going to be
on money so guess it worked.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: In that
vein, you mentioned earlier
that a lot of things are from
1902, and then you "yes, and."
RIKI LINDHOME: Yes.
So much stuff is true though.
People think we
make up this stuff.
Like we have cocaine wine,
that was just a popular drink.
We didn't make that up.
People had cocaine
wine all the time.
Just those kind of
things are just real.
Freud masturbating
people, it's just real.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: So that's a
real clip entirely with Freud?
RIKI LINDHOME: Yes, that
was not Chris Parnell.
That was Sigmund Freud.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI:
All right, great.
Thank you so much for being
here, we really appreciate--
RIKI LINDHOME:
Thanks for having me.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: --it.
If anyone would like to
meet Riki afterwards,
we'll be right here.
RIKI LINDHOME: Right here.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: Yeah.
If you didn't want to ask
your questions directly.
Thank you so much
for being here.
RIKI LINDHOME: Thank
you for having me.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI:
Everyone, Riki Lindhome.
RIKI LINDHOME: Thank you guys.
[APPLAUSE]